hey guys my name is Jess McDowell it is
monday the seventh of July and you're
watching games but news the bells and
sledgehammer games are promising that
suits their versions of Call of Duty
advanced warfare skipping last gen it's
let them take full advantage of the
power of the ps4 the Xbox one and the
Steep co-founder Michel Gondry is saying
that leveraging the system's
capabilities is their singular focus and
their three-year long development time
means the title will be top notch for
those unaware the yearly call duty
franchise is rotating development
between sledgehammer infinity ward and
treyarch there will be xbox 360 and ps3
versions of advanced warfare but these
are being produced by deadpool creators
payments studios Condrey has said that
it was good for them not to need to
produce all five versions simultaneously
saying and decoupled us from worrying
about having to do a split platform year
like titles had to do last year so that
was really refreshing and gave us some
freedom to really go after this one now
for a spot of beyond use Sony have said
they've made a significant investment in
their headset project Morpheus and don't
think virtual reality is gonna be a
passing trend Sony Computer
Entertainment CEO Andrew house has said
it's definitely more than an experiment
with made some commitments we're putting
significant investment into the product
house praised the technology further
explaining we do now think that we can
get to this point of delivering a
magical sense of presence where your
brain tricks you into thinking you're
actually in this place we think there's
something there that could be really
really interesting for a next frontier
of game development house Teddy's not
sure if the technology will have
mainstream appeal but he said that at
the very least it's going to be another
really interesting advance for the ps4
ecosystem and another way to deliver
brand new experiences that's what we're
about he also mentioned that after
seeing game creators passionately left
onto oculus rift they wanted to jump in
and see if they could do the same with
project Morpheus speaking of the oculus
rift the company has had some trouble
selling the devices in China since
apparently a whole bunch of them were
brought up just to be sold at a huge
markup this has resulted in a
countrywide suspension of rift sales by
the company a representative of oculus
VR said we need to make sure that we're
doing what we can to make sure that
resellers that are looking to flip a
product for a profit are not taking
stock away from legitimate developer
purchases globally our product in its
current form is a developer kit meant
for developers that develop VR content
not all is lost though oculus are trying
to find alternate ways to get rifts into
the hands of legitimate depths in China
so if you're a Chinese dev tuned into GS
news today and I believe that is a large
part of our viewer base don't fret last
off the mark today the Microsoft Store
has listed Kinect for Windows v2 at 200
bucks the company are accepting
pre-orders for the device which will
launch officially on July 15 that's the
same day as Microsoft's upcoming virtual
reality training event which is designed
to show developers how the gadget will
enable speech gesture and human
understanding in applications and
experiences before you feel like the
price is off the wall in saying it's
really mainly targeted at dev to develop
practical applications and not your
average consumer or gamer let me know if
you're keen to jump on board with
virtual reality or if it's not your
thing and why in that comment section
down below those are all the things are
going to tell you about today but i'll
be back soon time and place tomorrow so
i'll see you then